[Musique]
Monsieur en mode survie comme les émissions d'écho
tu n'as plus de jouets j'ai vu Blacula
Socrate je fuis elle voit le sang fait
tu es la personne technique pas politique
VidCon Camila je sous séquestre
Agatha sauf Allah a clairement laissé l'
accent de Séville 11 brouillon una  Bala personne
[Musique]
embrasse-embrasse une marque donc c'est critique c'est des
frais pas de BS okinawa mieux s'il vous plaît lancez-vous
à un lourdaud une infamie mata donc je le sens
couler dans mes veines obtient du manioc
dia ceci fait
Sakhi bien je peux exceller jusqu'à ce que nous partions
pas le temps d'être expulsé pour me dire jusqu'à ce que
nous partions, puis elle est venue à l'école
[Musique]
Volusia intouchable Mitchell Syrie MC
Connell Ageha capacités
Autodesk e-zpass une perte ne peut pas yova Greg
Lester
et je le sens me traverser le visage
et j'ai besoin de ce feu  juste pour savoir que
je suis éveillé
messieurs il y a quelque chose que je veux
vous montrer
aimer  qu'accepter une
clé du loft signifie que vous acceptez les
règles du loft dire à personne de
s'amuser  femme
ici Vinson je le sens couler dans mes
veines qu'est-ce que cela signifie que le destin nous unira
est-ce que tu gardes des secrets qui est-elle
nous savons travailler non jusqu'à ce que nous descendions
vous n'avez pas d'abord verrouillé les alarmistes
éteints quelqu'un est entré avec l'un de nos  clés
jusqu'à ce que nous partions combien de femmes avez-vous
emmenées dans cette serrure aiment jouer à des jeux
hein je fais quelqu'un essaie d'encadrer
une petite amie rejetée
petit ami jaloux quelqu'un avec un motif a
trouvé des gens qui ont été entendus découvrir
le  vérité que penses-tu qu'il va arriver
quelque chose de mal tu me dis Chris ce n'est
pas fini nous devons découvrir ce qui s'est passé
ici et nous trouverons une issue
et je le sens me traverser le visage
et j'ai besoin de ce feu juste pour savoir que
je suis  éveillé